hi there today we'll look at symbolic
knowledge distillation from general
language models to common sense models
by peter west and others of the
university of washington and the allen
institute for artificial intelligence on
a high level this paper takes a new
approach to symbolic knowledge
generation so to automatically coming up
with knowledge graphs with symbolic
knowledge graphs and rather than trying
to mine this symbolic knowledge
automatically from raw text or from
existing knowledge bases they mine it
from gpt-3 so they use the gpt3 large
language model in order to first come up
with a corpus
that gives them a corpus of symbolic
knowledge and then they use that corpus
in order to train a model that they call
a common sense model but essentially a
knowledge graph
completion model
so this is a new paradigm where you go
what they say from machine to corpus to
machine and it is their the paradigm
they advertise here in contrast to what
people did before the from human to
corpus to machine which is where humans
generate a corpus and then you train the
machine on that corpus
so we're going to look in into how they
do it it's pretty surprising what they
find in that for example the distilled
model the models they come up with at
the end they tend to be
better not only than the humans or the
human fed models they even tend to be
better than the original teacher the
gpt3 teacher and this is a result of how
they combine the different elements here
of the system and they strategically
they strategically bring in outside help
in the form of human knowledge so this
could be a recipe for
much more broad applications not only
knowledge
knowledge graph generation but various
natural language tasks they combine
cleverly prompting training small models
and as i said bringing in small amounts
of human annotated data strategically
so
as i said we'll go through it we'll look
at the different stages and yeah tell me
what you think in the comments subscribe
if you haven't and let's dive in
but first a quick word from our sponsor
weights and biases your one-stop shop if
you're a machine learning researcher
practitioner a hobbyist a power user it
does not matter weights and biases is
with you from the inception of your idea
tracking your experiments to really
getting the fine details right
optimizing your hyper parameters up
until you deploy your model and track
all of your metrics not only does it do
that it also organizes your data sets
your models and you can generate super
cool reports from all of that in
addition to that it lets you have great
insight into what you research and what
you produce and all of this runs in the
cloud really effortless with a single
line of code though today i want to talk
to you about a yet not so well known
feature of weights and biases and that
is the weights and vices community so i
believe they recently migrated this from
like a giant slack onto this new sleek
community website it's a discourse based
forum essentially where you can get help
not only for weights and biases stuff
but also machine learning in general but
not only is it a help page it's a
discussion forum about all things
machine learning also they organize
regular events book reading groups and
paper discussions and so on so if you're
interested don't hesitate and hop over
to the introduce yourself thread and
take part in the discussion as i said
this is still a pretty young place but
it's bound to grow over the near future
and of course if you want any advice on
weights and biases how to use it what
the best practices are this is the best
place to do so thanks again to weights
and biases for sponsoring this video
it's an awesome system i invite you to
check it out and back to the video
so what's the deal with uh knowledge i i
i can't i can't read this without
without pronouncing knowledge
as knowledge so what you want to do is
you want to have symbolic knowledge and
in this particular case the symbolic
knowledge thereafter is um
what they they always have to have what
they call an event
and a relation
so an event
relation
an event they give some examples but
essentially the event is some kind of
situation that a person finds themselves
in it's common sense reasoning so it's
not like napoleon was born in france or
something like that i don't even know if
that's true but
it's not that it's common sense
reasoning so the event is a person finds
themselves in some sort of situation or
two people it can can be one or two
people then the relation is some sort of
um
well it's probably better we make an
example the relation is some sort of
this for example this is the situation
right here x starts running
the relation is these are predefined
relations and we deal with seven
different relations right here
the seven relations are chosen because
they represent sort of causal
causal knowledge one of them is effect
which means what is the effect of this
event or what is one possible effect of
this event and the goal of the model is
to come up with this thing down here so
you prompt the model by saying x starts
running
uh we have the effect relation so the
model is supposed to come up with the
effect of starting to run now there is
not only one correct example there are
many correct examples right here but one
example is x gets in shape this is not a
a direct logical you can't prove it
mathematically right or you can't check
it and that's why it's called common
sense reasoning the
a human would look at this says x starts
running um is the effect of that that x
might get in shape yes probably so that
is a valid triple
okay let's look at another one
um
let's maybe take one with two people in
it no
there is none with two people right here
let's see
x is not well liked that is the event
the relation that we give to the model
right here is the react relation
which means how how does a how does x
react to that event
so x feels lonely
and that as well kind of makes sense
right if you you as a human judge this
you apply your common sense makes sense
so i hope the task is clear given an
event and a
relation where the event can be any
anything like anything involving uh x or
x and y which are one or two people and
any piece of text right this is any
piece of text right here
and a relation the relation they are
seven different predefined relations
you have to give the the result right
here the inference and the inference
again can be any text
so this is quite a challenging task
right and humans have come up with a
data set for this task i don't know
where they describe it right here they
have come up with a data set called
atomic 2020
so the atomic data set is a data set
that where humans go and humans make
these triples right
it's a data set made by humans as you
would make data sets this takes a lot of
work costs a lot of money and we
would like to have methods for not
having to do that necessarily
so either to cut out the humans
altogether or to use the human labor
more strategically such that it doesn't
cost as much
and they also the the model that's
trained on this human corpus it's called
common sorry comet 2020 that is if we
simply feed the human corpus to a deep
learning model have it learn to predict
the inference from the event in relation
that model is called comet 2020 and
that's going to be our baseline and
obviously
we're going to surpass that so the
result of this paper is going to be a
another corpus called atomic 10x which
is
10 times the size of the human
atomic data set
which is going to be better or larger
and
with appropriate filtering also better
in quality than the original
corpus which is surprising right and
then also the comet distill
model which is the model that's trained
on the atomic 10x dataset and that is
going to be as well depending on the
filtering largely better than the
original comet 2020
model that's trained on human data
so that's the goal that we we get there
we get to a model that is better than it
had we trained on human data
and along we get a corpus that we that
is better than the human corpus
so
again the
original the original paradigm was
humans go humans think with their brains
like here from the brain
comes a corpus right so i invent a bunch
of corpus entries right maybe i'm many
like many i let many humans do this i
come up with a corpus uh manually then i
feed that corpus to the model to the
machine so there is a
neural network right here
i train the neural network on that
machine neural network thinks yeah cool
the new paradigm is the following
i take
a big giant neural network such as gpt-3
that is not necessarily trained on this
task right i'm gonna make gpt3 have one
more layer than the other network to
symbolize its absolute bigness
so gpt3 is trained on the whole
worldwide
is this a globe
this is a globe
gpt3 is trained on the whole world wide
web or at least readable part of it
and i'm going to use gpt3 in order to
come up with the corpus okay so i'm
going to use gpt3 to come up with this
corpus and then optionally optionally
i'm going to filter that corpus with a
model that i train on human data
so this is where the human component can
come in right here now
we're going to see how this happens but
the obvious the obvious
effect of this is that the human no
longer needs to come up with examples
the human simply has to rate examples
in order for the filtering mechanism to
get better which is much easier much
cheaper and we don't need as much i
guess maybe we do
but it's it's essentially it's much
cheaper for the human to rate than to
come up with stuff
so we use gpt-3 to come up with a corpus
and then we use that corpus to train our
model
so we're going to use the power of these
large language models to come up with
corpus and of course the magic is going
to be how are we going to do this and
the answer is clever prompting
so there's a bunch of math right here
about knowledge distillation i'm not
sure i guess they just had to put this
in uh to get accepted because you need
like a bunch of math and yada yada yada
but essentially it's irrelevant so um
yeah sorry if if you disagree authors
but
uh
yeah this is
it's essentially irrelevant
so
the key findings of the paper actually
we're gonna skip this because we get
this at the end
so what do we mean by clever prompting
we want to come up with a corpus the
corpus should have events the corpus
should have um inference relations the
relations of course we know the corpus
should have inferences
so
they have this general template for
prompting gpt-3
they start off with a task prompt where
you briefly describe the task
inside the prompt and then they have a
bunch of examples so the input the
output the input the output the input
the output and then they have another
input and this is the input they're
actually interested in and they're going
to let gpt3 complete the output right
here now given that they have the task
description right here and they have
this pattern of repeating inputs and
outputs you can get gpt3 to continue the
pattern and actually give you what you
want right here we've seen this a number
of times
right here this is called prompting or
prompt engineering and i i
predicted this right away when gpt3 came
out that prompt engineering would sort
of be
like is a quite an important thing to do
in the future so importantly we don't
train gpt3 we simply query gpt3 in a
very structured way in order for us to
create
um
a data set essentially i think that's
even against the terms of service of
gpt3 but they must have gotten an
exception here
this paper is also cool because it finds
a number of interesting things in
prompting now some of you might have
been aware of this others not but there
are interesting effects for example you
want to number these things right here
you want to label them with actual
numbers such as that
they say this increases the degree to
which gpt 3 follows previous examples
and
also
when they construct examples for example
like this x goes jogging they also say
if they replace x and y and so on by
common names it also works better so you
really wanna
i think it's yeah it's still a bit of an
art form to see exactly how you have to
phrase
the things you put into gpt3 such that
you get out something good so the first
task they're going to do is they're
going to create these events
ultimately we want to create the data
set but the first step is we create the
events
so they go to the atomic
data set this human generated data set
and
what they do is they simply
sample so they collect a set of 100 high
quality events from atomic 2020 to use
in our prompt
note that yes they do make use of the
human
corpus right here which is a little bit
unfair when you think of comparing to
that but given that it is a hundred
examples that is something you could
still easily come up with even even as a
researcher right or you could you could
pay a bunch of humans
100 examples isn't that much
so
we go
and we collect 100 and then
we simply every time we go to gpt 3 we
randomly sample 10 we put the 10 inside
of the prompt right we simply list the
10 events
for example
x overcomes evil with good
x does not learn from y and so on we
simply list that and then we put 11 and
we let gpt3 continue the prompt
right here and that here is going to
give us an a next event i guess we can
even let it continue more but
there are these issues like repeating
and so on so i'm not exactly sure how
well that would go
but in any case you can generate
essentially infinity events because even
if you even if you put the exact 10 same
events in the exact same order right
since you sample you sample with um with
nuclear sampling
it doesn't give you the same results
therefore you can generate a lot of
events in fact they generate
165 000 unique events
which is
as you can see quite a bit more than the
human authored corpus which only has 6.2
000 events and all you needed as a base
is 100 of these events right 100 were
enough in order to create
165 000 that is the power of these large
language models you can essentially
count on them already having built in
all of this sort of language modeling
all of this
well you might call it knowledge or you
might simply call it uh
data that they have absorbed but you can
query that in a particular way and the
way we query it here it gives us new
events
all right so this is the way pretty
simple that we create new events
now from these events we want to create
these triples right the triples are
going to actually make up the data set
so
for a triple remember we need and we
need an event
we need a relation and then we need an
inference
so the events we now have check the
relations there are just seven of them
they're always the same in this data set
so we have them as well so now we can
simply pair
take an event from the data we created
pair it with a relation and then we have
to come up with an inference and again
we're going to use clever prompting and
gpt3
so
what the authors do is that for each
relation they come up with a
they come up with a a textual
representation
of that uh relation
so the by the way the um
the relations are described right here
there is x adder how x is perceived
after an event how x reacts in response
to an event what effect does it have on
x
what was x's intent in event and so on
so these are the the kinds of relations
that we're dealing with right here they
give an example here for the need
relation which is here what x needed for
the event to happen
and their textual representation is as
follows so i'm going to put the event
with an event number right here
according to what they said at the
beginning it helps when you number the
individual entries
then they're going to write
prerequisites
for this to happen comma and then
the
actual inference goes here right until
here
so they're going to repeat this this is
they're going to repeat it 2 3 and so on
again they're going to put 10
samples into the prompt with the
inference filled out and then for the
11th one they're simply going to put the
event right here
and the prompt
that they
have already used and then they're going
to let gpt3 fill in the rest right here
and that thing is going to be the gpt3
provided inference
so
um
they say as in 3 2 we sample 10 few shot
examples for each prompt from a set of
100 human authored cases
for each pair of event and relation we
generate 10 inferences with the the
second largest form
following the same hyper parameters as
event generation
now they don't use the largest form of
gpt-3 because it would cost them too
much money
so they use the second largest one but
you do the same thing you you generate
just very very very few
human authored cases so that's 100 100
human authored cases
and um
i don't know if that is 100 per relation
or just 100 in total i don't know i'm
gonna guess
maybe
per relations
i don't know
it doesn't say just says we replace
anonymous names with generic names as
this improves quality however
it doesn't matter if it's a hundred or
seven hundred it's still
very very few compared to having humans
come up with an entire corpus so what
you wanna do is you simply wanna give
gpt3 a little bit of input like 10
different things of input and these 10
things you may vary a little bit over
time you might not even have to and
let's not forget the task description up
here that also seems to be important
and then they come up with
a hundred and sixty five thousand times
seven
inferences
which you can filter a little bit but in
the end this results in
6.46 million atomic date atomic style
data triples
they call it atomic 10x as it contains
an order of magnitude more triples than
the atomic 2020 with respect to the
seven relations they investigate
so this is a giant corpus right now of
machine generated
of machine generated data i'm trying to
find table one where they compare the
size right here okay so here you can see
just the the comparison of um what that
cost you can see the total count in
atomic 2020 is
600 000 triples and atomic 10x has 10
times more triples yet cost only a
fraction of what atomic 2020 cost
now the um
the question is of course
is this data set any good you know this
here at least has been generated by
humans you know humans aren't perfect
but at least they have some common sense
therefore for a common sense data set it
might be important
does the atomic 10x data set is it any
good and that's what they go about
investigating right now
so
they evaluate
degenerated common sense knowledge graph
so they evaluate now these triples first
of all they look for diversity so they
have a few diversity related metrics
such as like hard diversity or this what
they call blue soft uniqueness where
they check for overlap between the
triples and look how many of them are
unique um they also look they also try
to train a gpt-2 model and look at the
entropy of the different data sets
and
in general they find that the machine
generated data is quite diverse as quite
high entropy there's not much of a
problem right there it's also quite
unique
it is not as unique
it seems as the human generated data but
given that you have so much more of it
the absolute number of unique things is
way way higher
the real kicker comes when you do actual
human evaluation so they have spent a
lot of time into humanly evaluating the
quality of
whatever they produce
the humans have been asked to rate these
triples into
for example always often so
when you see
an event a relation and an inference you
as a human have to say does this
inference always or often come from the
event and relation is it sometimes is it
likely
if you said one of the two it would be
accepted the triplet would be counted as
good if you as a human say ah that's
kind of far-fetched or that never
happens or is invalid
then um
you would you would uh
reject the triple
if you look at this
then
you can see right here in the
human authored data set the humans
accepted 68
of the triples and rejected 11
whereas this top row right here is the
unfiltered data set we got from gpt3
with the prompting and you can see that
the accept probability is slightly lower
actually quite a bit lower like eight
percent lower and uh humans also reject
more often and even sometimes not
available means they you can't make any
any judgment on it
so
the number is it's way larger right but
it's a bit lower in quality as assessed
by humans as it seems so now they gear
up
they say okay can we make this better
and their answer is yes by introducing a
critic
so making the teacher model more
critical
where they go about the following they
have this formula right here maybe that
math isn't as useless after all
so if you simply generate language you
simply have uh gpth3 be a model uh a
probabilistic sequence model a language
model that simply says what is the
probability of the next token and i'm
going to sample by that probability
but now what you can do is you can
introduce a critic so if this is your
language model can introduce a critic
and the critic also will have an opinion
on how likely a particular sequence is
so now you consider both you can you
generate data with gpt3 and then you let
a critic evaluate that data which
essentially amounts to multiplying the
two probabilities but
in in practice you would simply run the
critic on the data and then the critic
decides is this data good data or bad
data and that together
gpt3 and the critic they uh
you hope that they will produce a better
data set than just gpt3 alone because
now the critic is able to filter
whatever gpt-3 says and only let the
good data pass
note that i i think it's
maybe the critic is is probably capped
at one or something like this so this is
a filtering mechanism it's not like you
can you can introduce new bad data so we
would expect that the filtered corpus
is is hopefully better the question is
how much better is it
okay so now we introduce this critic and
the critic
is now is where we strategically bring
in human
data so the critic would remove
unacceptable knowledge in practice this
means filtering the generations in the
large corpus and creating a range of new
corpora that are higher quality yet
still larger scale than the human
the human
authored one
so for this
they gather a training set of correct
versus incorrect humans
human judgments on a randomly sampled
set of 10k entries of atomic 10x
so they take their large corpus they
take 10 000 entries of it and they let
humans rate those 10 000 entries much
like they did here for the evaluation
but this now
counts as this now goes as training data
for the critic and that's where i said
we strategically bring in human
knowledge and not only do we
strategically bring it in rather than
letting humans generate the entire
corpus we also make it easier for humans
because this isn't coming up with
examples coming up with examples is hard
it takes time
these humans here they simply need to
read examples of the corpus these 10 000
examples and for each one they have to
rate it
and this can even be noisy
so other than in the evaluation where i
think they gather three labels per data
set they say we only gather one
annotation for each example
so this can be noisy since it's training
data and
yeah that seems to be quite a
quite a good way of thinking about human
labor in machine learning it's sort of
where can we bring it in to make the
biggest difference
now when they do that
yeah so they argue this here it's vastly
cheaper than human construction
instead we argue that a more useful and
efficient role for humans
in knowledge graph construction is to
correct the mistakes of the teacher by
evaluating a small number of examples
so they train a roberta large model
on the human annotated data as the
critic the critic of course doesn't have
to be a language model it doesn't have
to generate anything it simply has to
look at the data and decide is it good
or is it not good
so they train that
and
end
yeah
now we go back to the table right here
these
here
as we go down the table
more and more filtering is applied by
the critic so now you have a choice as a
designer right you have this critic
model it tells you about how good a
particular
sample is and now you get to decide the
cutoff you know how much do i want to
filter this data right here
now this will have a trade-off the more
you filter the smaller the resulting
data set is going to get
so we can look at a few examples
for the first step you go from 5.6
million that's for sorry from 6.5 to 5.1
which is a reduction in somewhere
between uh somewhere on on the order of
20 of data so you throw away 20 percent
of data look at that the accept
percentage jumps from 78 percent to 88
so now human raters
human raters rate these triples
in the corpus that you generate and then
filter
as more
likely more acceptable than the corpus
that was offered by humans like this is
this is astounding um already
right now there might be a little bit of
an effect here in that probably
the humans that raided were the same
humans or at least you know humans from
the same
population or distribution then
the humans that raided the training data
for the critic and therefore
all of these humans might sort of have
the same taste whereas the humans that
came up with the atomic 2020 data set
might be
you know different humans i'm not sure
but it is astounding and even more
astounding as you filter more you can
clearly see the accept percentage
therefore the quality of the data set
going up and to the point where you keep
about 40 percent of the data that you've
generated from gpt3 yet the the accept
percentage is like 96 which is a 10
higher 10 percentage points higher than
the
accept percentage of the human generated
data right this is quite this is quite
astounding and still you have like four
to five times more data than the human
created corpus
and they do some they do some um
they do some evaluation also again on
the diversity of the data and actually
turns out that as you go as you filter
more the diversity increases so that
would be the relative diversity meaning
um sort of how
how many percent of the data are
you know different from other how are
unique and so on so
it appears to be that
gpt3 when it just creates data it will
create a lot of good stuff but also some
garbage and as it turns out the garbage
seems to be
always the same kind of garbage
therefore if you filter out the garbage
also the uniqueness and diversity of
your overall data set increases so it's
quite the opposite of you know you
always hear this uh
no i guess i guess it's that the the
saying that um
all
was was it all unhealthy families are
the same we're all healthy ones i don't
know but in this case all the garbage
gpt3 produces is kind of the same kind
of garbage or or the same few types of
garbage whereas all the good stuff it
produces is relatively unique
all right so now we have a really yeah
this is what gets filtered out right
here um
so first of all logical misalignment
consists of events or inferences joined
in a logically inconsistent manner now
that makes sense that that gets filtered
out x cannot find his shirt as a result
x is wearing a shirt yeah that should
probably not be in there
and two awkward phrasings which consists
of events or inferences that in
isolation are incoherent ambiguous or
awkwardly phrased so when an event
itself is already
poorly phrased the model essentially has
no chance of generating good inference
like
person x has a fire in the bath
yeah so there there's just um there's a
high chance that a human would would
negatively rate this or not accept it or
say it not available
um
even like from the get-go doesn't even
matter what the relation and the
inference is right
so the last step is
the last step is
we want to go back to a model so we have
taken gpt3 a model we have used it
strategically to come up with a corpus
that is both
better in quality more diverse and
larger than the corpus that humans have
generated
and now we want to go back to creating a
model from that corpus so i want to
train an inference model because right
now we can only generate data but we
would like to have an inference model
and remember the original task
the inference
is
to
given an event and a relation
to produce and to produce either produce
an inference
right which you could do with gpt3 but
it's it's sort of
um
not super good so you have to filter
with the critic but that means you have
to like sample until the critic says
it's okay what you'd rather have is
you'd like to have a model that is
trained on this data to produce directly
the inference rather than having to
prompt gpt3
right so the model
can be way smaller than gpt3 because
it's directly trained on the task and
you don't have to pay open ai every time
you call it
so
now i want to go back to a model and
that's pretty easy right we simply take
a
the same architecture as this comet
model remember the comet model is the
model that's trained on this human data
to do this inference simply take same
architecture and we train it on the
large corpus
and
you know what what
turns out so on
it turns out that
we do that and then we let again humans
rate the triples that the models produce
so for the
comet 2020 this is the
model that's trained on the human corpus
this here you can again see the accept
percentage by the raters of of the
corpus itself
when we train the model on it to do this
inference for us
the model
produces triples that get accepted 81
of the time which is pretty good right
so if the corpus gets accepted this much
we train a model on it an nlp model
uh
it's pretty good to drop only a little
bit
in the accept percentage that means the
model has essentially learned because
this is obviously on a on a validation
set the model has obviously learned to
do this inference
somewhat correctly
now
if we do the same on our large
corpus
that has lower accept percentage we see
the same effect so the model kind of
learns in fact overall we see the same
effects if we now add a critic
with a low threshold
then
uh we surpass already
this model and we if we add a critic
with the high threshold so that would
correspond to throwing away 60 of the
data as we saw before then the model
that we end up with has an 87.5
accept
uh rating so now we have a model that's
the same size
as this comet 2020
right
it is
an a
trained model it's not gpt3 it's not
prompting it's a trained model that does
inference in these triples
and it is better it is better
than
the model the same model that's been
trained on the human
corpus
which is pretty cool right so
you even you you it not only does it
surpass
uh gpt3 itself
it also surpasses the human generated
data
and yeah
that's pretty cool
so this was essentially the the findings
of this paper i guess we can go back to
conclude with what they said at the
beginning the key findings right here
learning symbolic knowledge from
language models can be framed as a
symbolic extension to knowledge
distillation okay so
that's the that's the mathy part
symbolic knowledge distillation
constructs a high quality knowledge
graph at scale
okay that's their data generation
process
a critical teacher results in a higher
quality student
you know granted the critical teacher
makes
the quality of the data set better and
therefore any model the student that is
trained on that data set it will become
better a notable ingredient right here
is that here is where we actually bring
in the human
human annotated data into this process
of automated knowledge graph generation
because we need to train that critic
critical teachers or not a student can
outperform the knowledge source
so this is about that the student model
they exceed the quality of gpt3
which
so if you simply prompt gpt3 you get
some of these triples right
yet the student models that are trained
on these triples that come from gpt3
outperform gpt3 which can make sense
since gpd3 is a general purpose language
model and these student models are
specifically trained on that particular
kind of data
and also
i have to say the student models they
are
they're gpt-2
so in the student model what you would
do is you have your corpus
you have event relation inference event
relation inference right these are your
samples
this is this is all text essentially
right so the relation you can abstract
that in a either a single token or you
can make it into a text as they did so
they feed that into
a gpt-2
which is something that you can train
and that gpt-2
is
trained to take in
an event and a relation into the context
and then generate the inference much
like gpg3 but now you actually train it
specifically on this
particular
data structure and data set and the
gpt-2 you pre-train it of course on
language modeling
and it could be
that some of the effect that the
students model exceed the quality of
gpt3 might be due to the fact that it
starts out already from a gpt-2
checkpoint
it it's it's a positive like there's a
possibility that that also plays into
the game right here
machines can now win over humans for
automatic knowledge graph construction
so
that is a little bit
is a little bit is a little bit shady um
since the critics you train are still
using humans um but i would agree that
at least
the paper shows that there are better
places to use human knowledge than
letting humans come up with a text
corpus because these text corpora can be
generated pretty easily using large
language models
and proper prompting
and if you do that then you can use the
human knowledge to filter whatever the
language model's output and that might
be much more effective
so
this was it for this paper i hope to not
only show this paper but show give you a
little bit of an idea of what all is
possible with these language models and
proper prompt engineering and i think
this serves as a little bit of a recipe
for many um or a lot of things to come a
lot of nlp tasks to be done
could be tackled in this particular way
all right so yeah let me know what you
think in the comments
and
bye